More than a third of the world's smokers are
Chinese.
For every $1,000 of music sold, the average
musician makes $23.40.
If your stomach acid got on to your skin it
would burn a hole in it.
Three-quarters of French people take their
annual holiday in France.
Tokyo has three times as many Michelin-starred
restaurants as Paris.
Many of the doves released at the opening
ceremony of the 1988 Seoul Olympics were accidentally
roasted alive when the Olympic flame was lit.
During WWII the Russians built a tank that
could fly.
One out of every 21 New Yorkers is a millionaire.
Electrons move along an electricity cable
about as fast as honey flows.
Before the Queen of England puts her shoes
on, a member of the royal household wears
them first to make sure they are comfortable
+.
Every year, a thousand letters arrive in Jerusalem
addressed to God.
Only three of the original 60 clauses of Magna
Carta are still in force.
In Italy, 13 is not an unlucky number, but
17 is.
The Netherlands exports more soy sauce than
Japan.
Ants nod to each other as they pass.
During the 1880s existed The Thirteen Club,
they formed to debunk the superstition surrounding
the number 13, during meetings they would
dine with 13 people at the table and spill
salt on Friday the 13th.
The club has 5 US presidents as members, Chester
Arthur, Grover Cleveland, Benjamin Harrison,
William McKinley and Theodore Roosevelt.